it's touching it's funny it's
informative it's it's full of history in
your show it clearly shows how Massey
and Isis live their lives for people
that don't know can you explain what
being too spirited is so being too
spirited is that you accept your mail
and your female side so for me I look at
it as like I can embrace my masculinity
and I can embrace my femininity and so
when I embraced it I ended up creating
Isis reign we've both agreed Massey and
I to focus on our mental health I'm
going to start all over again when did
you first introduce yourself as as Isis
I had went through a lot of trauma when
I was a child
I didn't realize that I was
disassociated so when I was 18 I created
Isis ring I dressed up as a female and I
went out and you know for that moment I
didn't experience any pain or suffering
I just felt so free I realized that I
have this whole other identity in this
whole other life through Isis reign and
that she never experienced being abused
it was almost like she took the pain
away from me together we we just fought
back against diversity I want to find my
masculine side do you think they would
let me fight like yeah sure have you
been able to see in your own personal
life how you and IFS have been able to
inspire others when people message me
and say I saw your show or or I attended
one of your anti-bullying events or you
know I actually took the rope off around
my neck and you have given me courage to
be Who I am you know that makes me I
cried to hear that you know these people
are messaging me and saying you give me
hope that means the world to me because
that's exactly why I chose to show my
life the nicest range life on TV was
it's not because of the fame it's been
as if I could share my story and if I
could just help one person to believe in
themselves and to know that they are
worth life then that's that's what I
that's why I did I did it and that's why
I will continue to do